c'est la dernière journée de vie de
marcel bouchez demain il mettra fin à
plusieurs mois de souffrance
une décision qu'il a prise pour lui mais
pour partir en toute quiétude
il a aussi voulu penser aux autres
l'homme de 59 ans sera le onzième
québécois à faire don d'organes après
avoir reçu l'aide médicale à mourir un
message d'espoir
pasqua - dr fed d'un et mes ardeurs pas
et que je n'en ai lévis ont contraint je
vais des neiges a poursuivi blanc leur
but un cadeau de vie c'est un
commencement nouveau pour quelqu'un
d'autre
marcel bouchez pourra donner ses deux
reins et son foie les trois organes ont
déjà trouvé preneur dans celle voisine
oui en gros oui mais en juillet dernier
marcel bouchez se portait plutôt bien
malgré des douleurs chroniques liées à
un accident de travail survenu en 1997
il était sur ses deux jambes et ils se
mariaient avec sa précieuse sylvie après
23 ans de vie commune
six mois plus tard il est confiné à son
fauteuil
ouah son lit le diagnostic est tombé en
octobre
ce les roses latérale amyotrophique
depuis son état s'est détérioré
rapidement ce qu'est ce qui vous manque
le plus mal en point dans votre compte
d'abord c'est quelque chose que tu m'as
maintenant la même paire de deux femmes
dans la trentaine kelly et christina
marcel bouchez est aussi grand père
d'une petite fille
une deuxième doit naître le 11 février
mais il n'a plus la force d'attendre sa
naissance pour partir je joue plus à
quelques heures de quitter ses proches
il espère qu'on racontera ses petits
enfants que sa décision était aussi un
geste de générosité
quand leur parlera de lui comme d'un
homme au grand coeur
j'ai jamais eu peur de la mort je marche
même en invoquant marcel s'est éteint le
lendemain de notre rencontre
mais une partie de lui vit toujours
grâce à son don d'organes comme il le
souhaitait ici marie pierre bouchard
radio canada shawinigan